[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages
heute mit
guten abend ihnen allen kurze
unterbrechung der sportberichterstattung
aus münchen wir bringen sie in den
kommenden zehn minuten auf den neuesten
nachrichten stand unter anderem mit
diesen themen
ab oktober wird es teuer seit heute ist
die höhe der gas umlage für
privathaushalte und unternehmen bekannt
hotels gegen kardinal woelki nach neuen
enthüllungen distanzieren sich
mitarbeiter im kölner erzbistums von dem
65-jährigen
unschuld start mit hindernissen der
lehrkräftemangel hinterlässt deutliche
spuren
die höhe der gas umlage ist raus 24 19
cent zusätzlich für jede kilowattstunde
darauf müssen sich ab oktober alle
einstellen die mit gas heizen heißt zum
teil mehrere hundert euro mehr pro jahr
durch diese umlage dazu kommen noch die
ohnehin steigenden kosten für gas zu den
reaktionen gleich mehr zunächst erklärt
anton kuh schicken die details
weil russland weniger gas liefert müssen
die systemrelevanten gasimporteure zu
hohen preisen ersatz kaufen um ihre
lieferverpflichtungen etwa gegenüber
stadtwerken erfüllen zu können
die folge die gasimporteure drohen
pleite zu gehen um das zu verhindern
greift der staat mit der gas umlage ein
es handelt sich dabei um
ausgleichszahlungen
gasimporteure wie juniper konnten sich
dafür melden die gasanlage liegt vorerst
bei 2,4 19 cent pro kilowattstunde sie
wird monatlich abgerechnet und kann alle
drei monate angepasst werden gelten soll
sie bis april 2000 24 jeder der gas
verbraucht muss die umlage bezahlen
industrieunternehmen genauso wie private
haushalte mit der gas umlage von 2,41 19
entstehen in einem single haushalt mit
einem durchschnittlichen jahresverbrauch
von 5000 kilowattstunden mehrkosten von
120 euro 95 pro jahr ohne mehrwertsteuer
eine familie im einfamilienhaus
verbraucht im schnitt 20.000
kilowattstunden
hier entstehen mehrkosten von 483 euro
80 pro jahr ohne mehrwertsteuer hinzu
kommt dass auch die gaspreise wohl
weiter steigen werden
das ist alles eine folge des russischen
angriffskriegs sagt wirtschaftsminister
habe und verspricht dass ärmere
haushalte entlastet werden karl
hinterleitner berichtet wie teuer ist
wird verkündete heute ein fast
unbekanntes unternehmen trading cup
europe tochterfirma der deutschen
gasnetzbetreiber gab am vormittag die
höhe der umlage bekannt mit gut 2,4 cent
nicht so viel wie befürchtet dennoch
eine weitere belastung für verbraucher
und wirtschaft die aber müsse sein ja
sie sei sogar überlebenswichtig so
robert habeck diese umlage ist die
gerecht möglichste form die zusätzlich
aufgelaufenen kosten in der bevölkerung
zu verteilen und zu tragen die
alternative ist nicht keine umlage die
alternative wäre der zusammenbruch des
deutschen energiemarktes gewesen
alternativlos oder nicht in jedem fall
ist die umlage eine finanzielle zumutung
die deutschen haben angst vor einer
kostenlawine
viele familien sind schon am limit was
ihre einkommensverhältnisse betrifft und
gerade die die so viel verdienen dass
eben nicht gefördert werden für die
würze zeigen ganz klar das wird im
niemals gedacht an die rentner ich bin
selber rentnerin bekommen eine
grottenschlechte kleine rente ich habe
richtig gearbeitet und ich finde es ist
wieder wieder die kleinen menschen
müssen dran glauben ich ärgere mich
kolossal auch die opposition war viele
bürger seien schon jetzt überfordert ist
ruhe eine soziale schieflage
das problem ist ganz grundsätzlich beim
belasten ist diese koalition sich sehr
schnell einig nur beim entlasten warten
wir seit wochen es wird jeden tag
gestritten es gibt jeden tag einen neuen
vorschlag kleinere und mittlere
einkommen brauchen diese entlastung aber
dringend die leiden jeden tag unter den
hohen preisen uns schwebt vor dass
anstatt die menschen an den heizkosten
verzweifeln zu lassen so wie auch der
mieterbund warnt die bundesregierung
sich endlich aufrafft den politischen
findet die deckelung des gaspreises
durchzusetzen beim preis deckel aber ist
nicht in sicht wie hoch die rechnung für
alle am ende ausfällt weil es jetzt noch
niemand das hängt auch davon ab ob
russland den gashahn weiter zudreht
es müssen also entlastungen herr theo
koll in berlin dafür braucht es aber
auch einigkeit in der regierung oder ja
also das ist weitere entlastungen geben
soll das hat zumindest der bundeskanzler
gerade auf seiner skandinavien reise
nochmals bekräftigt denn gaskunden sind
ja künftig doppelt getroffen durch
teureres gas plus die gasanlage die
große streitfrage wird sein wie die
entlastung bezahlt werden soll und da
knirscht es erheblich in der ampel der
spd chef fordert heute ähnlich wie auch
die grünen von energiekonzernen die
durch die krise gerade besonders viel
verdienen eine über gewinn steuer
einzuziehen der fdp chef und
finanzminister hat uns aber erst gestern
hier im zdf vehement versichert nicht
mit mir die frage wird auch sein wie
groß ist der kreis der zu entlastenden
gaskunden und wird auch vom gas
abhängiger unternehmen geholfen also
viele industriebetriebe klagen ja sie
müssten bald ihr geschäft einschränken
oder aufgeben also klappt sich
formuliert zumindest die
regierungskoalition braucht im herbst
keine heizung denn die parteien dürften
sich ausreichend selbst einheizen
dankeschön nach berlin theo koll
welche kosten entstehen durch die gas
umlage was ist zu beachten in der zdf-
heute- app haben wir antworten auf die
wichtigsten fragen für sie
zusammengestellt
die ursache des fischsterbens an der
oder ist weiterhin unklar der unmut über
spärliche informationen aus polen wächst
sie seien nur kleckerweise gekommen
kritisierte brandenburgs
ministerpräsident weiter bei einem
besuch am grenzfluss helfer hohen seit
tagen tonnenweise kadaver aus der oder
bei der analyse des massensterbens will
man nun zusammenarbeiten
experten einer deutsch-polnischen
taskforce sind in engem austausch
sechs tage nach der präsidentschaftswahl
in kenia hat der vorsitzende der
wahlkommission einen sieger verkündet
mit einem hauchdünnen vorsprung liegt
der bisherige vizepräsident will foto
vor dem langjährigen oppositionsführer
raila odinga
allerdings distanzieren sich vier von
sieben mitgliedern der wahlkommission
von dem ergebnis direkt nach der
bekanntgabe kam es zu protesten und
unruhen
vor genau einem jahr übernahmen die
taliban die macht in afghanistan
kämpfer der extremisten gruppe feierten
heute den jahrestag auf den straßen
kabuls am 15 august hatten sie den
präsidentenpalast gestürmt zehntausende
menschen versuchten damals das land zu
verlassen die bilder vom evakuierungs
chaos am flughafen in kabul gingen um
die welt
nach köln dort brodelt es im märz bistum
kardinal woelki habe sein letztes
vertrauen aufgebracht aufgebraucht
schreiben 60 pfarrer und andere
kirchenleute und fordern einen neuanfang
das fass zum überlaufen brachten neue
enthüllungen der seit jahren umstrittene
kardinal hatte eine pr agentur engagiert
um besser durch die missbrauchskrise zu
kommen dort erwerber
geschlossen moralische bankrott eine
protestaktion heute am verwaltungssitz
des kölner erzbistums die wut in köln
ist groß nach dem pr papier des
kardinals emotionen zeigen joker haben
sollte welche bei der missbrauchs
aufarbeitung rieten ihm
kommunikationsexperten ein papier wie
ein drehbuch in der zeitung zu lesen
das nennt sich wie überlebt der kardinal
daraus wird ersichtlich dass es auch
immer darum ging seine position zu
schützen und ihn zu stützen und sich zu
überlegen wie er im amt bleiben kann
dabei hatte woelki stets versichert bei
der missbrauchs aufarbeitung gehe es
genau um die betroffenen menschen wie
karl hauke instrumentalisiert und
entsetzt jetzt kann ihm doch keiner mehr
vertrauen
also eigentlich müssten eben alle seine
berater stäbe und der betroffene beirat
und
alle gremien des des bistums müssten ihm
kündigen mit dem menschen kann man doch
nicht mehr zusammenarbeiten eine
stellungnahme woelkis fehlt bislang doch
der widerstand formiert sich immer
stärker 60 pfarrer und
kirchenmitarbeiter auch leitende
distanzieren sich vom kardinal die zahl
wächst auch die laien im bistum fordern
einen neuanfang das system works
kollabiert komplett und es schadet eben
nicht nur in anführungszeichen dem
erzbistum es schadet der ganzen
deutschen kirche ich glaube es ist zeit
wieder eine auszeit zu nehmen und die
kann durchaus auch dieses mal länger
dauern köln und sein kardinal die krise
dauert an
der rundfunkrat des ard senders rbb hat
patricia schlesinger als intendantin
abberufen und zwar mit sofortiger
wirkung damit wird die vertragsauflösung
in die wege geleitet der 61 jährigen
wird unter anderem vetternwirtschaft
vorgeworfen die berliner
generalstaatsanwaltschaft
ermittelt gegen schlesinger
nach nordrhein westfalen starten heute
auch schleswig holstein und mecklenburg
vorpommern ins neue schuljahr alle eint
ein seit langem bekanntes problem es
fehlen lehrkräfte bundesweit mehr als
23.000 in den nächsten zwölf jahren sagt
die kultusministerkonferenz der verband
bildung und erziehung spricht sogar von
über
158.000 über die folgen berichtet bernd
mosebach
zurück in ihrer buchenbergschule im
mecklenburgischen bad doberan auf dem
stundenplan der sechsten klasse steht in
dieser woche auch physik eigentlich
müssten es zwei stunden sein doch weil
es an der kräften mangelt ist es nur
eine ab der siebten klasse führte
physikunterricht gleich ganz aus
richtige ausgebildete physik lehrkräfte
zu bekommen es im prinzip unmöglich weil
dort auf markt einfach gar keiner mehr
ist und ja wir sind dieses jahr wirklich
das erste mal in einer situation wo wir
einfach nicht anbieten können der
verband bildung und erziehung warnt vor
dem drastischen lehrkräftemangel die
prognose der bildungspolitiker ist
weniger düster der unterschied gibt sich
vor allen dingen daraus dass die
kultusministerkonferenz davon ausgeht
dass jeder der das lehramt auf der
studium für das lehramt aufnimmt auch
lehrer wird und hinterher zur verfügung
steht wir wissen dass es aber eine
erhebliche zahl von studienabbrechern
gibt beim studium für regionale schulen
ist die abbrecherquote mit bis zu 80
prozent besonders hoch ein bisher
ungelöstes problem
wir werden alle register ziehen müssen
das heißt mehr quer und seiteneinsteiger
aber es heißt auch dass wir die
teilzeitregelung in den einzelnen
bundesländern überprüfen müssen mehr
flexibilität ermöglichen der beruf muss
attraktiver werden allein 700 lehrkräfte
braucht mecklenburg vorpommern jedes
jahr um die zu ersetzen die in rente
gehen in der buchenbergschule läuft der
physikunterricht erstmal weiter auf
sparflamme
der deutsche wetterdienst warnt vor
schweren gewittern und starkregen im
süden von mecklenburg vorpommern und
teilen brandenburgs wie es dann
weitergeht sagt gleich katja honnefer
bettina schausten freut sich auf sie um
22 uhr 40 im heute journal ich wünsche
ihnen einen schönen abend und viel freie
freude weiterhin bei den european
championships live aus münchen
[Musik]
guten abend endlich kam heute mal regen
meist in form von schauern und gewittern
es entwickelte sich eine konvergenzzone
luft aus osten und aus westen strömten
zusammen und am nachmittag gab es diese
kräftigen gewitter von der nordseeküste
bis zum erzgebirge mit diesen gewittern
haben das jetzt doch noch am abend zu
tun in der nacht ziehen sie weiter nach
nordosten einzelne gewitter kann es auch
noch in ostbayern geben die temperaturen
sinken auf 19 grad auf den
ostfriesischen inseln und bis 10 grad am
alpenrand und liegen morgen zwischen 26
und 32 grad da wird es hier in der
lausitz oder zum beispiel auch in der
lüneburger heide am wärmsten in
süddeutschland gibt es morgen viel sonne
norden allerdings mehr wolken und da
kann es auch mal für einen kleinen
regenschauer erreichen und an der
ostseeküste könnte es auch mal ein
kleines gewitter geben und dann kommen
die kräftigen schauer und gewitter von
westen heran die werden die hitze aus
deutschland vertreiben am freitag gegen
die höchsttemperaturen nur noch bei 18
bis 26 grad guten abend